hello everyone I hope you're all having
a wonderful Sunday and if not it's
vasilyev on shift to the rescue this
game comes as a suggestion from a
subscriber Nikita tereshchenko not so
much the game but the interview with
vastly von Schuch held by Tanja sajdah
the official YouTube channel the trade
wise Gibraltar chess festival published
yesterday even though Gibraltar chess
festival finished like two weeks ago but
they only publish the interview with
vastly von Schuch yesterday so I will
put a link to it in the description
below I suggest you check it out and
there's really nothing for me to even
analyze here in the video because lastly
von Schuch analyzes the game blindfolded
in his postgame interview so I
definitely recommend you to check it out
it has the video only has like 1000
views and I don't think that's
acceptable and interview with mostly
once you should get at least a hundred
thousand views so I don't I don't think
I can get it up that high but I can
definitely help a bit so do check it out
it's it's like pure 12 minutes of chalky
madness and joy so let's see this game
Chucky has the white pieces and he faced
he faces team GUI I think you remember
her I I think I did two videos on her
from the world blitz and rapid
championship she won the 2nd place in
the world rapid championship for women
so and it's interesting event Rick says
that for preparation for this game he
decided to play efore and see what
happens so that was Avengers preparation
for this game and his opponent plays
east 6 so here is a vastly von Schuch
against the fringe we had d4 d5 and now
not going for Knight to c3 as he won
Chuck says this is a bit too aggressive
for white he goes for Knights to d2 the
tarush variation we have c5 now Knight
to f3 see characters on d4 Knight
captures and Knight to f6 we have a
captors on d5 Queen captures on d5 and
here your knight on d4 is obviously
attacked you have to do something about
this Vasily chooses to go night-night to
to f3
saying that this might not be the best
move but you know it's solid and here if
I should suggest something like Bishop
to c5 but King July goes for Bishop
3:7 and here we have Bishop to d3 and
here Avant truck says that black can
choose a a more safer approach or a more
aggressive and creative approach black
could definitely go for something like
castles castles and a6 and this is very
solved for black but you know eventually
was very glad to see this I mean maybe
not at the moment it was played but
after the game he says that he was very
happy his opponent decided to play
creatively here 'if I've was played and
this is a discrete and extremely
complicated position yeah your knight is
attacked after your knight moves efore
is a very big threat so you do have to
definitely do something about this if
one goes nice to b5
I'm getting his Knight out of the way
and of course you can't push efore
immediately if you push me for
immediately then you get Knight to c7
check you lose the Queen and the game so
here things you like castles now of
course you think you can go night to c7
now and maybe for the Queen and the rook
but if you win Knight to c7 this would
be a very sad day for you as black could
play Queen to a5 this comes with check
and you lose the knight on c7 so this
would be definitely a terrible day for
you gonna choke so after castles avenge
of Castle as well and only now comes see
for and it seems if I'm chopped is
losing the piece not really if I'd
replace the knight back to c3 attacking
the Queen on d5 and now there's also a
double attack on the e4 pawn and the
thing July goes for Queen to c6
unfortunately you can't go Queen to a5
with the idea of still winning a piece
because now you just lose a pawn after
Knight captures only for Knight captures
and now Queen to e2 attacking the pin
piece
there's no way to defend the night you
you're losing a piece and most likely
the game so after Knight c3 Queen to c6
and here we have 9th to d4 other than
this night the d4 move event you had
some very creative ideas for example
rook to e1 if pawn captures Bishop den
Broek captures on e7 this would be very
good for white but he said that he was
afraid that after rook to e1 black could
play Bishop to b4 now pinning the knight
on c3 and now even trick says that he
did have a couple of ideas
for example Bishop captures on e4 and
now if Knight captures now go Knight to
d5
what's the idea that if black captures
rook then Knight to e7 check checks the
King of course and forks the Queen
but the problem is black doesn't have to
capture the rook immediately black and
simply play rook to d8 pin this night
and now black is just winning and he did
have a couple of other ideas but in the
Indian he gave up on it and decided to
go after this Queen to c6 to play Knight
to d4 attacking the Queen we have Queen
to b6 now now the night is attacked on
d4 and also the Bishop is attacked on d3
so here Bishop captures on e4 now the
queen is defending the knight on d4 we
have rock to dat pinning the night and
now Bishop to e3 and this is the
position that makes this game very
interesting here things you like play
the Queen captures on b2 and the Evangel
wasn't very impressed with Queen
captures on b2 a von Schuch was really
thinking a lot about this position and
he saw some very interesting radius for
black for example he thought about
Knight captures on e4 and after Knight
captures on e4 not capturing on b2 but
rather he thought about the move f5 and
he thought if she decided to play this
then then he could very well be lost
because now if you go Knight to c3 then
f4 and black is winning your bishop is
trapped here if you pull the bishop back
you lose the night and before simply
recaps or something forcing happens if
you captured yeah for pawn but then even
took tried tried some other ideas after
f5 he considered Knight captures on f5
opening up the attack on the black queen
and b6 buddy this is the variation he
shows in the interview once again I do
hope you will check out his interview as
it's really amazing after Bishop
captures on f5 now Bishop captures and
b6
rook captures rook captures pawn
captures Bishop on b6 and now c3 he
thought this would be an interesting
move because now if Bishop captures any
for rookie won both bishops are under
attack
so after okay for defending b3 now the
rook
nowhere to go to still be defending the
bishop on e4 and after okay three
now you capture but after Knight to c6
he thought okay I'm up two points but
she does have a knight and the bishop
for my rook and also I have a week a to
pawn so he didn't like this position but
then Yvonne Chuck says that he was very
happy when he saw this idea after f5 he
saw that he could actually play Knight
to d2 and this night the d2 move is
actually the reason why I put this quote
above the board as vastly von Schuch
says the most difficult in chess is the
C moves with Knight back so now white is
actually perfectly fine because now if
you push therefore white easily meets
this with Knight to f5 attacking the
bishop on e7 and now the problem is if
you capture on e3 is simply Knight
captures on e7 with check and if you
play Bishop to c5 then nice t7 check
again and you can't capture the night
because you lose the Queen and b6 so
after King h8 now event would have
Knight captures and c8 attacking the
Queen you have to solve this first solo
captors night and only now Bishop
captures on f4 and everything is
perfectly fine if I choose up two pawns
winning this game so like I said after
this special treat removal he considered
a lot about this Knight captures a me
for Knight captures an f5 but his
opponent didn't go for this she went for
the immediate Queen captures on b2 and
he says that even better if if she
decided not to go for that complicated
line she could have capped she could
have played Knight captures on e4 Knight
captures and only then Queen captures on
b2 because now if she plays Queen after
some b2 and eventually goes Queen Queen
to d3 which was played in the game now
if she ever decides to capture on e4 now
we went you can actually capture on e4
with the Queen and give up his c3 Knight
for the for this e 7 bishop which would
be definitely good for white but okay
knife to a6
you don't have to start developing and
here comes rook a to be one attacking
the Queen you want to consider the
bishop to f3 getting a special part of
the way but then
if we spread three night before can be
kind of annoying attacking the Queen and
III and also the pawn and c2 you don't
have to give up a pawn with Queen to c4
or you have to play Queen to d2 which is
really passive so after night to a6 we
have rook a to be one attacking the
Queen Queen a3 and now Bishop to f3
getting his Bishop out of the way and
here if I was thinking about Bishop to
b4 for black and he thought that this
would be this would be fine but I think
July played nice to be for attacking
divine troops Queen and he was very
happy when he saw this move now Queen to
c4 as there is no threat of actually
capturing the c2 upon and the Queen is
quite active on c4 and here Bishop to d7
and at this moment when Bishop to d7 was
played of course the material is equal
everything seems fine and the position
is in fact about equal
the problem is King July it has less
than five minutes on the clock and event
has like an hour and 15 maybe 20 minutes
on the clock so now we won't you said
his plan was mostly not to make like a
really primitive move like a terrible
blunder and simply you know make little
threats about two or three moves so you
know he was actually playing against the
clock at this point so we had Knight see
to b5 attacking the Queen Queen to a5
and now Bishop to f4 the idea of course
is Bishop to c7 attacking the Queen and
the rook so but should capture some b5
night characters and we have Knight to
d5 Bishop to g3 and now rook a to c8
Queen to b3 we have a six and now Knight
to a7 unfortunately you can't trap the
night with rook to e8 because your b7
pawn is hanging so rook to c3 and now
Queen captures an b7 here event grabs a
pawn we have Queen to c5 and now comes a
for h6 and now comes Queen captures on
a6 and rook captures and c2 so after all
is said and done teams July is still
very low on the clock and the event you
created a very strong past a pawn so
nice to b5
now we have night to be for attacking
the Queen Queen b7 and now rook to d7
attacking the Queen again
now Queen to be a Czech rock blocks and
now Queen makes her way all the way to
c7 forcing an exchange of Queens rock
the seat but now Queen captures rook
Bishop captures and now you can see that
the Queen's are off the board a von
Schuch still has his a very strong past
a four pawn and this is simply winning
for white especially with a very long
time on the clock Knight to d6 attacking
the rook rook back to f8 and now comes
rock to c1 again forcing an exchange of
rooks Rock captures rook captures
attacking the bishop and c5 now Bishop
to b6 trying to stop the past a pawn
we have h3 and here rook to d8 was
played and in this position King July
resigned at the game I don't really have
the information did you resign or what
she may be solo on the clock that she
didn't really find any any inspiration
to continue playing this game but either
way it's a lost position for for black
event you can actually win this game
immediately so it's pretty good position
for you to pause and you know enjoy it
and find the winning move so I will give
it a couple of seconds if you want to
check it out for those of you who were
able to solve this very nice position
congratulations you're an excellent
player and for those who if you just
want to enjoy the show if you found a
five a five also leads to a win for
white with the idea that if a bishop
captures then you have Knight to b7
but there is an even stronger move rook
to be won simply attacking the knight
the bishop is behind the knight and the
problem is if you play Knight to d5
defending the bishop on b6 then simply
Bishop captures Knight captures and rook
to b5 attacking the bishop and the
knight and black can't stop both threats
so yeah that's the game from round 9
vastly von Schuch against team 13 July I
do hope you enjoyed it
once again I invite everyone to check
out the interview with vasily von Schuch
it's it's really amazing one of the best
interviews I've ever seen with vastly
von Schuch and you know do share your
comments on that interview as well as as
well as the game so I would like to
thank Hobart Chappell
gofredo Matthew BL oh uh no forget C and
the Gilmore rally for a contribution to
my channel thank a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon most likely with another game
from the 1959 candidates tournament
thank you all and I'll see you soon